[Laughter]
so anyway
i know you don't like um hi i know you
don't like compliments
um you get a little uneasy about
compliments
so i just try not to swing it your way
yeah why can't we just keep doing what
we're doing here
no because i think that'll be way more
because it wouldn't be tiger belly if i
didn't
you know what i mean maybe weird make a
little weird but um
i'm just going to tell you how i
discovered you
right you know i i do owe my whole
career to you yeah
i was i don't know i was struggling
until no obviously not covered
not discover you in terms of like you
did it on your own obviously but no
in terms of my my awareness of you
oh can i tell you that story i remember
it was a big day in my career
bobby lee is finally aware of me
am i on bobby lee's radar see this is
what he's doing this
is when things start to happen i'm not
going to allow this to that reversal i'm
not yeah i'm not going to allow this to
happen very soon yeah yeah
i'm just going to plug away you know
what i mean listen you can talk to him
all you want
i can hear it
plexiglas it's not sound proof so years
ago years ago um
i had no idea who you were and um i was
in a car
with steve byrne and ken jung and we're
fl
i'm driving from san francisco to l.a
because we had to do gigs together at
that time
because we couldn't draw on our own and
so
uh stephen loved oasis we kept playing
oasis over and over again like he still
does i know right
it's like give it a rest right they have
three songs
good songs champagne supernova wonder
wall
and some other one okay don't look back
in that that's it
great songs but that's it so he and i we
go what do we listen to nikki and he
goes
well i have a friend from new york you
know he you're
you know we have his comedy cd and we're
like we just said well i want to
listen to [ __ ] comedy right now bro
what the [ __ ] yeah you know
we're [ __ ] eight hours in the [ __ ]
[ __ ] with some open mic
[ __ ] seat or whatever right he puts
it in
no it was very funny but there was one
bit about you in the subway and then you
saw
some guy pick a girl up and then your
high-pitched voice you i mean oh yeah i
was grabbing it by the back
and we laughed so hard and that's when
you know me and went out oh bill
bill bill burr and then um
now you're one of the greatest comics
on the on the planet
how does that feel
what's that character you just i don't
even take it no it's just
i'm plugging away i'm doing all right
you're doing all right
well it's great because of the fact that
it's like you know
here's here's the deal the honest truth
is this
i just love that whole body like okay
here's here's the deal
let's get ready let's get real so um you
know i'm almost 50
and i feel like um things are kind of
slowly happening for me as well right
it's just nice to see like you know what
you've been on [ __ ] television for
like almost 30 years
what are you talking about mad tv oh my
god and everything
okay first of all mad tv was like doing
community theater
that's how much we got paid i'm not well
i'm just i'm just talking
i'm just telling you i know did you get
[ __ ] over in show business
did you think there was a big pot of
gold and somebody else took it from you
yeah that's what happens but you were
still on tv
you still walk down the street and
people like oh my god it's bobby lee
from mad tv okay fine fine you're right
and i'm grateful
okay but i'm just saying the amount of
empathy that i have
for you right now is just awesome
how much of your day is trying to pick
this up
[Laughter]
and keep it yeah buoyant i know
see the thing about him though i have to
stand okay yeah yeah go ahead think
about him
i feel like i'm getting cross-examined
yeah thing about him is
that he he has a ways he's one of those
guys like whitney
is like that too where she sees you know
me behaving in a certain way to garner
some sort of sympath
sympathy or you know i'm doing something
psychological
right so that i can get something out of
something and he sees through it where
other people
they fall into it and they go oh no you
know and they you know i mean
i i've just been around a lot of dirt
bags
i've been taking advantage of a couple
of times i know when it's happening yeah
but you could see through that but i'm
just saying that um
let's go back to what i was doing
originally which is um
you're doing well and congratulations
that's all i wanted to [ __ ] say thank
you
i appreciate that i appreciate that i
mean you're killing it
i love the mandalorian right you all of
a sudden
i didn't even know you were on it and um
when you're watching something you love
right and then you see a guy that you
know up there killing it
you go oh my god it's [ __ ] crazy
right
and then like and then he's in the the
the apatow movie
and uh but you know he's killing it
that's all i wanted to say
i know you don't like compliments i
caught up to you i know you don't like
compliments
why don't comics why do comics not like
compliments
i know i think some of them do look i i
respect
you know other comics liking what i do i
do enjoy that [ __ ] but i don't want to
sit here
and and just like listen to that
you're giving him the worst experience i
just want to like hang out and take
whoever's watching this
laugh you don't have to go james lipton
when you did that [ __ ] joke on comedy
central yeah
because this is your first time on this
podcast right
yeah so i just i need to get that out of
the way i'm a big fan of it too
i always put the little heart on all
your clips i always think that they
always think it's funny
thank you and so you know from now on
when you do it i will never bring it up
right i just had to say it you know to
put it on record
oh put one on record that you know the
uh how
i discovered you and you know what i
mean
with a discovery this gave me how you
know how i feel about you
you know i feel just real good tingly
warm feelings towards you that's all
well thank you
yeah and i think you're doing great
stuff that's awesome we don't have to
[ __ ] talk about it whoever knew that
my career would come down to a car full
of asians driving up
some german irish guy from massachusetts
who knew
i needed the west coast asian connection
discovered hey guys we're taking a
really quick break to talk about one of
our favorite sponsors brooklyn
usa each and every day
you guys brooke linden is a product that
kalila and i my beautiful honey bunny
here
we we use brooklyn in our house and it
just makes our relationship
and our lives more comfortable and